las propuestas se han centrado en cómo
atender la crisis del costo de vida con
una inflación disparada y también la
crisis de la energía y es justamente
aquí donde se han evidenciado las
grandes diferencias entre los candidatos
sobre la política fiscal del reino
unido- bajar o subir los impuestos
mientras que ellis tras que la actual
secretaria de exteriores ha dicho que
reversar a los impuestos que subieron en
abril y que no habrán nuevos impuestos
en el país richie zona que fue hasta
hace pocas semanas el ministro de
finanzas del país dijo que no bajará los
impuestos y que sólo podría hacerse en
el futuro cuando la inflación del país
esté totalmente controlada ha dicho que
no va a mentir y se ha presentado a
diferencia de listas como el candidato
del primer ministro del el cambio listas
también ha dicho que para atender la
crisis de la energía se debe seguir
explorando nuevas alternativas en el mar
del norte pese a que esto iría en
contravía de los compromisos adquiridos
por el reino unido en el acuerdo de
glasgow tras la cob 26 y también ha
dicho que está a favor el fracking ri ji
sung dijo entre otras que acabará con la
inmigración ilegal e implementará ese
polémico tratado acuerdo de ruanda que
enviaría a todos los inmigrantes
ilegales especialmente los que llegan a
través del canal de la mancha a ruanda
que es un país altamente criticado por
sus bajos estándares en la protección de
los derechos humanos y cuéntanos luisa
cómo será exactamente este proceso para
elegir sucesor de boris johnson
como lo mencionas se está realizando en
el wembley harina aquí en londres el
último acto de campaña los integrantes
del partido conservador unas 200.000
personas tienen hasta este viernes 2 de
septiembre para enviar vía correo físico
su voto a favor de regis una polis tras
los resultados se conocerán este lunes
al mediodía -hora local- luego el 6 de
septiembre será el último día de boris
johnson como primer ministro y por
primera vez en la historia el primer
ministro saliente visitará a la reina
isabel no en el palacio de buckingham
aquí en londres sino que irá a la
instancia de la reina en balmoral en
escocia dado que la monarca que la jefe
de estado está presentando desde hace
algunos meses problemas de movilidad ese
mismo día el nuevo la nueva primera
ministra asumirá funciones también
visitando a la reina isabel en escocia
de esta manera entonces isabel segunda
conocerá a su 15 primer ministro en este
reinado de 70 años